all right so let's go to cou
Naga and put this patter this
understanding into cooking n okay uh
first let me say I don't do every single
technique that the IAI tells me to
do
um it's I I I heard one guy used this
phrase it's pretty good so I'm just
going to borrow it there's like um a
correspondent
inflation because the way that yinong
manifests itself uh and it goes on and
on and on and
on um what has happened in Silk Road
culture due to in my opinion an EG
tripartite
mind um surge that happens always
happens it happens at a social level and
it'll happen at an individual
level um you get lost in this
pairing and pairing and pairing and
pairing and it just goes on for
forever um I think o Sensei had
correspondence inflation uh it's one
reason why I leave the internal
terminology so simple there's yinong and
the da there's Ike and KQ I don't don't
talk about Pang and L and all the
different types of Jin uh I don't I
don't talk about that stuff it's that's
just crazy it's going to lose
you so I don't talk
about um the elements too much I don't
talk about uh the numerology that goes
with everything the directions all that
stuff that o Sensei got lost in in my
opinion and that many modern aikidoka
who who look to O Sensei they just get
lost in that too uh in in my mind
because that is a byproduct of the EG
tripartite mind ultimately it is all a
kind of idolatry which is the true only
sin you can do
okay so I don't want
to get to uh where I make every
technique and and I have to do every
single technique for every
single uh grab or every single
strike I don't do that some techniques
when you do that they don't make sense
and you're just pushing it too much uh
you're stretching it um instead I just
work because the Keon are energetic
rituals I just work within those rituals
that describe describe or not describe
but manifest more what is trying to be
manifested which is the mystical
experience so
um many of you have said like can you do
this technique or can you do that
technique and like with hundreds of
videos that we have now you should
probably be asking why doesn't he do
that technique because that's I
don't do that technique okay and I have
humored a few of you but I think you
should probably question why do you feel
the need to have every single technique
for every single queue if these are
energetic rituals that are ultimately to
be
transcended so likewise when it comes to
kokun nag I don't do
kokun at jodon level for example
although it is very common to do at
jodon level I don't do it at Joon level
because you have to
uncheck the person in order to check
them again and that makes no Marshall
sense I think most people do jodon
because it allows them to wind up the
arm uh much more and generate more Force
so it's a muscle Reliant external Force
engine uh that is doesn't make any
Marshal sense at all
okay so I'm going to answer the the
questions on kokun Naga from gon
but if you want to do it at jodon just
remember how to transition from gon to
jodon and then you do you
okay
in this kind of
geometry I
know that I have to utilize the
centrifugal uh and centripetal energies
of a circle I know have to have a
constant 90°
modulation uh uh in light of UK's mass
inertia
momentum and so I can't ever adopt this
180 and 180 degree to UK's Mass uh
inertia or momentum okay I also know
that in order to use the centrifugal or
cental energies I have to be in the
middle of the circle
okay so the takeaway from what I just
said the overall pattern must be spiral
in
nature and I must not adopt
180° Vector to UK's Mass inertial
momentum at any time and I must be in
the middle of the circularity of the
Spiral okay but when you look at most
cun Naga the way it's done uh the UK is
coming in
let's say from my left to my right okay
they're coming
in and what the Naga does who maybe
starts somewhere over
here is at best if you pay attention if
you slow down the
video and then go frame by
frame you're going to have the NGA does
their Tenon here
okay so if you look at this relationship
and you plot it in space Here's the tip
ofas um
Force I am not generating this circle I
just have two independent points at this
at this point and the worst part is that
this is actually a turn and what ends up
happening is
at a certain moment
as I turn in my Tenon here my back is
actually to ukit which is not Marshall
at all that is totally wrong
okay but what the good trained Uka does
is they keep coming by and now you've
reconciled that Marshall problem which
would never be reconciled in real life
okay so now the now the UK is over
here okay and then you end up
accelerating them more this
way the throw happens you you send your
Force this
way and this accelerates the UK this
over here and then some here some where
in here for some reason the UK does a
forward rule they go Topsy Turvy okay
but if you look at this
shape there is nothing in here that
resembles anything that we just
said and in fact you're doing the 180
violation and here's
why for you to accelerate UK in this
direction which is what you're
doing you're on their 180 and all you're
doing is overpowering the inertia to
maintain their whatever acceleration
they have at that moment you now you amp
y it so you're just pushing on them
that's all you're doing if you weren't
able to overcome the inertia of their
given velocity at that time you would
not be able to throw them at all you you
wouldn't it and uh I think anyone has
had this experience who's done this
version which is
ubiquitous you've come through the ranks
and eventually you got your 200
pound male you're small and they're just
standing there holding on to you you
can't overcome the resistance of the
inertia given within their velocity so
you cannot accelerate them or you've had
the other experience especially with new
people is they just walk out of this
thing because acceleration does not
warrant Topsy
Turvy any anybody that could meet your
accelerated level could keep the line of
gravity within their base of support and
they would just walk out he says not
Marshall in any way there's no attack on
UK there's no reconciliation of attack I
am actually practicing
contestation and I haven't used any of
the iido stuff and if and that's if I
get past the back exposure that happens
okay so we have to change this and the
way we're going to do it is exactly like
we did yesterday with
Ed so the energy is coming from left to
right UK is doing this
okay and I will start the initial spiral
Rotation by my movement okay so anytime
that an attacker is coming this way
you will always move at the
angles okay and what happens in this
case is in your own deviation your own
angle deviation the UK has to course
correct to whatever degree okay and so
now they just in you moving in essence
the target at one of these diagonal
angles they have to Force correct to
keep the their angle of attack on target
okay and that starts the
rotation if there's a huge great deal of
force you'll generally use these two
angles if there's not a huge great deal
of force you can use these two angles
okay in the standard kihon waza of kokun
Nag I'm going to go from here to
here
okay where
I when where I
step cannot violate this rule of
exposing my
back so we have to pass each other
meaning
when if this is UK's front
I have to
step at a wind wear that when we reach
This Plane we reach it at the same
time okay if I reach it early earlier
than
UK If I'm here and here's the plane that
I want to get
to if I reach that plane earlier I won't
have deviated they would turn
immediately right there it's now just a
new straight line
okay so if here's that plane where I'm
going to meet UK I have to meet them
here at the exact time that they got
there then I'm here and now my back is
not exposed okay and what I'm using is
as I'm traveling there I
starting that actual thing that would
have been used against me I want them to
reorient themselves but my angle is too
acute and I end up on the side of them
with them kind of more coming from this
angle okay so they're not totally doing
this angle
anymore it kind of looks like
this they kind of go like this boom that
was it that's all I need to start the
rotation
okay so I'm here
now and when I throw now I turn within
this
area okay and as I enter that spirals
out and here's where the throw happens
because I'm in this middle spiral that's
ever
expanding and the centrifugal energy is
now established from where I am and that
is what is added to UK so I'm not just
throwing them and speeding them up here
the centrifugal energy right here of the
circle is what's accelerating them out
they go okay but that's only one of the
three forces that I use in the
throw I want to generate that outward
pulling energy to do that we can't make
this shape we have to make this
shape a very very easy way to understand
this if this is your
dojo
okay most people do this technique and
all the Naga and UK end up and they get
their
Lanes this is
[Music]
incorrect if this is my
Dojo UK is not going to go from this
side to this side UK is going to go from
this side to this
side okay that and that causes a problem
for a lot of Dojo but you know what
off figure it out is how that's how it
works okay I've been in some little Dojo
like in Japan I trained in a in a dojo
that would rent the space of a
kindergarten classroom and um the dojo
was so small and everyone's doing uh
Tristan if you don't mind like let's say
we're doing yesterday's technique okay
and they would do it like this
and it's like it's too small in
here they they adopted the technique to
the environment he like No And I was
like I'm not coming here
okay
um do you get what I'm saying it's like
that's stupid but that's how people are
people are stupid that that Dojo was
about goes down the street I could just
walk there you're not learning the Art
Walk someplace else it's that simple
okay so sometimes here we split them out
in half uh we might turn or something
like that and we look for the this
pattern that the trajectory of the UK is
going to go this way not this way this
is incorrect okay all right so let me
show you what I was talking about just
now okay so in our Dojo the ocean is
South the ocean's over there and then
the mountains are North
awesome sound bar okay so this is West
and this is East so in most
Dojo the um the person is going to come
from West and then go
east okay and if comes from the other
side same thing okay in terms of
trajectory in in my trajectory he's
going to go this way
again he came from that way he has to go
the other he has to go
this
okay uh in terms of most people we slow
down so I can talk a be smooth okay is
it go like here you see that and that go
slower please scoot
back it comes in
back see and that is not true that's not
correct
okay what I want to do instead is meet
him you see I meet
him so that I have his
back the reason why people have to do
the other thing is because they have to
accelerate him so for
example let's say I don't do
it I get in the back of him do you
see and uh now I try to accelerate him
down keep your I Tred to accelerate him
down and you can see when I do that that
his inertia of the upright position is
now being contested with when I cut down
on you okay
if you now watch this I get I go ahead
and I get in the
box and I look now for the checked
unchecked okay he's unchecked right now
till I'm
here put pieces together okay if I could
get in the
back whoops come on okay and I use
uncheck and
then okay now I want to add the third
piece uh just one out of the technique
instead of doing a forward R okay so I'm
here
Bo you're going to have to do it harder
going to have to contest
more there's no way he could he would
have to fall in that there's just no way
if I could even overpower him
okay uh he's actually stronger than me
don't let me cut your hand down get
it not going to be able to do that okay
but if I do the turn in front of him to
expose my
back you see then I can put his hand
further out in front of him making it
easier to accelerate him do you see how
I'm doing that it would be no it's very
much akin to
this because I can step and go forward
but that doesn't really change anything
so let's exaggerate the fact that I turn
in front so that I can accelerate more
again if he wanted to run out of it he
[Music]
could and
again if you wanted to resist he went
right
there
okay but people are looking
for more range more leg use so they can
do more
acceleration that's that's not I
okay part of the problem
there is the Ten
conon so when they t con they go into
this
stance now I only
have 6 in of
acceleration this is why every beginner
figures out you want me to accelerate
and they will always go like this they
will always step cuz they're trying to
get more acceleration they will always
[Music]
turn
okay that again is all
so we have to change the way we think
about this technique he's not going in a
straight line I will not turn in front
of him he's going to do this
curvature towards the
90 and and the next thing is I'm not
going to
do
this I will end up
putting my foot right behind the other
foot so that instead of 6
in I have my full base for whatever edme
penetration I need
this will allow me to single pivot point
turn this will allow me to be the circle
and this will allow me to do the second
of three elements for the throw okay so
I know I want to get theal
energy that's one energy of the throw
the other energy is going to be my Emi
angle
as I'm bringing him across I'm going to
attach the
leg I'm not accelerating him I'm going
to spin his body in place
okay so in I'm behind going this
way stay up with
me in and behind is going this
way cental
energy anding behind my leg go
the third element of the
throw
is the adhesion at the
hand to get his
elbow
stay to
drop so we know that his body has
inertia and I don't want
to excel accelerate it against it but I
also don't want to push it down so he
his inertia is keeping him in place in
an erect posture so what I'm going to do
is 90° to it so I keep doing this with
his hand keep moving it
around it's no different than when he
was down
in and he tries to bring his head up I
brought his head forward I now do it in
the half
okay and when you do that his body is
going to go across your leg and you get
to use that second Force I prob so I'm
going to go one two
the adhesion open your grip okay the
adhesion is what's doing
it don't use his fingers don't use his
fingers you're in the Palm moving
you can do it without the leg um sweep
especially for IDs that aren't used to
this you just kind of go a little
shallower but you keep the same powder
so it's instead of uh attacking this leg
boom
there I just go a little shallower but I
do the same
patter
shaller
shall
sh if you watch my body now you can see
how much I'm
turning you watch my body now there's no
turn turning
turn in
[Music]
okay play with me some uh common
mistakes very very common in this
technique um one
is his arm that that originally
generated the angle cancellation to
generate the zone of sanctuary that I
turn in you get rid of bit let his arm
straighten again and just to pull down
on his grip so his arm should never be
straight once the technique starts his
arm stays in this position okay the
second one
is it usually happens because you're not
strong enough for the mass that you're
uh resisting so the UK will come up you
see and then you take them back down
it's like a little merry go around to
this thing okay so you're here and they
come up and then you
go
um
again you're in the wrong place and
you're doing the wrong thing okay so he
shouldn't come up and then done you
should let him up and he shouldn't make
you have to go up the only reason the
arm is coming up there's only two two is
you're winding up for the for the cont
contestation against his his standing
inertia or two uh you're not taking it
forward and it's overpowering you okay
if you're taking it Forward cuz there is
you are going to feel that but when you
feel that inertia as he starts to lift
your arm go ahead lift it you keep
bringing it
Forward again that's what I mean when
I'm here he starts to lift his head you
don't want to come up you just bring it
forward it's easy that's the 90°
modulation
okay so every this hand just stays where
it's
at never comes
up never comes
up his elbow Never B uh never straighten
even though my arm straighten
his elbow never
[Music]
straighten he never comes up okay try to
we had a question here and uh in my
explanation I I presumed the answer when
I said the phrase you using an Nike
adhesion inside the Palm okay um but go
back to the gripping video that I made
and if we just look at his hand his
fingers are closed
you see and so that means although his
body is coming forward like this as I
said in that one video there is a a
force Vector going back that
way well if that Force Vector is going
back that way then the 90° is here I
don't want to
go back like this which you tend to get
when you go like that you see when I
turn in front of you
with my back exposed there's no way that
I can't pull on your fingers there's no
way I have to pull on your fingers and
then the same thing is happening here
okay his
palm is that ledge I talked about that I
now want to push upon you see and on the
on the bad Thro on the contestation
throw and then his elbow opens you pay
attention my arm straightens and now
you're pulling on the fingers cuz the
fingers are going that way and this is
why a lot of people that do this they
the UK can't keep their grip cuz you're
ripping out of it okay or if they're
strong enough they keep their
grip you're like ah you're killing my
wrist you're rope burning me and then
you'll see the people with the tape on
there it's usually like older people
whose skin splits or women with smaller
wrist or men with smaller wrist you're
going to put tape on there instead of
realizing I'm pulling on the fingers
that's all that means
okay
so when you do this you don't pull on
the fingers your fingers are telling you
there's a wall here Dave don't come back
this way push instead
push see I'm pushing this way that is
why if he opens his fingers I still
making the wrist go if he closes his
fingers I don't use the fingers to do
it the fingers are telling me 90° to
this
place and when you do that his elbow
goes
in when you don't do that or you only do
it halfway
his arm straightens you get a little
turn here that's all the elbow you get
can you see and when you saw my elbow
it's freaking like this do you see and
now it's in a lock it's a lock it's the
lock of Sho nag okay and now it affects
everything I took all the slack out of
the joints you see now it can be a ledge
that I can do things
on meaning allege in the sense that from
there I can control more of his body
both yes
externally then internally I'm doing it
too okay so you're going to feel that
you stay inside the
grip how you can't just do a circle if
you just do a circle eventually you're
going to pull on it so you have to do
the spiral you see so there's a
downward right as is it coming this way
you
[Music]
see it doesn't just go Circle then
you're going to pull it goes
down in and
around and when I throw my throw is not
made up of the same ego tripartite mind
acceleration mod
so if you pay
attention I don't
really put any oomph into
it so when I come around I'm just
here my hand does lower towards the mat
but it's because my body
lowers so there again is
nothing on my okay certainly not just
okay so work on this part first and I
think maybe task you with getting his
arm here instead of here okay here
there's no zone of sanctuary here it's
just it's about to form but it didn't
form okay you want this totally closed
off and then his body is going to go
around the centrifugal energy is pulling
you
see let's go back where I had you dude
okay there we go he's going to go
around foot's going to
hit the centrifugal energy is going to
start doing this I make sure this leg
goes out even more and I drop come back
keep your arm where it
is and I Dr keep your arm where it is
and I drop this part he goes like
this okay
look how much it
in
in okay try